playing half naughty okay
yeah unfortunately i don't get a gm
title
by beating gm's only chess it only comes
from like
slow classical tournaments um okay so
we're playing
kind of a critical line in stafford
this is a jonathan tronce magical
stockfish crusher variation
so idea f3h4
computer gives like plus three but
it's fun especially for bullets
it's nice my phone's thinking here too
the problem is if my opponent plays a
move that's not
in my prep then
i might be in trouble but
yolo
i vaguely remember looking at this
actually
i mean like how to take on each two i
mean there's g2
let's take on h2
[Music]
i don't have to check my path here
um work f1 i have queen h4
and king d2
oh that bishop g4 so king d2 bishop g4
meanwhile i'm threatening g2
and we're playing like cutting edge
stafford gambit theory
so i'd rather not mess this up here
the thing is it's probably already
losing for me
that's such a cool position though
takes
bishop e7 as well
now let's um i'll start with rook h1 and
then go for this move
okay now i might be running out of steam
but
i'm only down the piece
yeah thing is getting trapped i have rig
h3
bishop here i can take hit the queen
first
i still hope
i don't know what a5 does
i should have played queen here actually
okay this does it gives my rook room it
lines with the king
a5 might discourage king b3
okay
so rook f2 i have this move
the bishop is pinned it's such a weird
position
d5 i take because there's a pin that way
too
and meanwhile this is a skewer
oh and the bishop's hanging knight e3
was a really
oh wait what's going on takes and takes
up the exchange somehow
um
wow that was a bad move let's take that
okay i'm up a ton of material don't
perpet me
i don't think i'm getting perpetted
wow what a game that was a fun game a
stafford gambit
like cutting edge lila weird theory
i'm actually curious how this compares
to what i
i'll analyze this at some point
um real quick let's analyze
so i was more prepared for this um
i'm sure we can find jonathan's games in
the
in the database but there's a cool line
uh rook g1
h6 g3 h6 g3 rook h2
dc5 bishop e6 queen d4 and then
this is um jonathan trance innovated
this
this
whole concept bishop c4
um yeah
people should check out the video on uh
on jonathan's youtube channel
um so this is one cool line where black
gets like a lot of
compensation
i'm just curious what we went into i'm
gonna
real quick uh i just have to open up
chess base
i went through a phase about a month ago
i was studying like some of the most
critical stafford lines where white just
tries and refutes
the whole opening like very much in
depth the line we just went into
[Music]
uh nordicky doesn't cover in his uh
in his video i wouldn't be surprised if
jonathan has more thorough prep but i
base this off
a few of his games
um so this is my prep and chess base
this is what i use to
uh to prepare things like
very very deeply
and this is not entirely a secret line
it's um it's known in certain circles
so my opponent yeah i have most of the
options for white from this position
my opponent um
[Music]
took on g4
i took and then bishop e3 okay
so takes on g4
hcg takes g3 bishop here
ah so this is one of the critical lines
um oh rook off one loses a tempo
wait did that happen oops
rook f1
does lose a tempo but my opponent played
bishop g1
oh wow it's already like close to equal
here
so the the line i studied should go rook
g1
queen h4 takes yeah it's a line where
black is down two pieces
and you turn on the engine engine will
save lights winning
yeah it'll say like plus six
but it won't find a productive plan for
whites i'll say knight a3 or some
random move and then rook d8 only move
bishop d4 here
oh yeah i think i was analyzing yeah
queen a4
black's already winning so bishop d4
it's a weird position where like both
sides are a little bit stuck
and we can turn on lila too i hope this
doesn't crash the whole computer
but lee levels sometimes give different
opinions
so i'm i'm sharing kind of my part of my
process with opening preparation
where there are certain types of
positions where stockfish and lila will
differ by a lot
and lila more understands like long-term
ideas
or just long-term nature of the position
so
it's usually a good sign like if lila
gives
a two-point difference in your favor
um there's some like underlying depth
that stockfish isn't getting
anyway this is this is very high level
stuff
um doesn't apply to
probably most people but i hope people
can still find this interesting
um this is just a glimpse of of how i
study openings
and this is not something i don't like
purely memorize all these lines i just
study to
i dig deep to try and search for ideas
and
and try and identify like the key
variations
okay i still have not broken into the
top ten
oh here's mamadirov
yeah a lot of people in top ten are
still playing too
hey stafford gamba time
so much fun seems good it's so much fun
yeah
so we're repeating the same line from
earlier maybe my opponent's prepared now
uh yeah we went into this rook f1 loses
a tempo
oh so opponent look this up wow
rick g won best move and then
[Music]
i think it's queen h4 and then i just
lose a bishop and then develop
like the bishop's hanging
yeah so this is exactly the prep i
showed earlier on stream
three hours until i have to be at work
going to be a long day today but it's
worth it watching you stream
i appreciate that so knight d2
the thing with knight d2 i can castle
[Music]
i'm just not sure if i should castle or
rook d8
i don't think it makes a huge difference
probably castling
it's a really bizarre position because
white's a bit stuck
but i'm also down two pieces
wait okay now i can take and this is
usually the idea when uh
the queen abandons the king like that
let's go
there's a few lines i think everything's
winning
i'm not sure though so i'd use queen h2
here
just writing mates that's so hard to
stop oh there's queen here
ah but then i can take oh but then
takes your queen f1
it's complicated
i'm not seeing the win actually oh no i
see i do see the win
takes i made into one
i'm still down a rook but i think it's
winning
because this is hard to stop
wow it's another nice it's so nice
the staffer gambit and this is like
cutting edge
again we went straight into the this
prepared line i showed earlier
in in chess base um
i could reopen just space to show it
again but
uh yeah i showed this position i think i
showed knight a three earlier
like knight a3 rook d8
i guess the difference between one
difference is
uh 93 prevents me from castling
but again um like sawfish gives plus
five
yeah it's it's so unusual to
like willingly go into a position that's
plus five
for the opponent was g2
g2 is not quite winning because
stockfish says so
also g2 bishop f2 or king d2
so it's important to just leave the
tension
and like the fact that the queen and
pawn are always aligned with the king
it just makes it really awkward to play
for white
and then there's some issue like king d2
yeah king d2 runs into bishop g4 and
then blocks winning
so again huge thanks to jonathan
transfer
basically discovering this line he
prepared this super extensively
to a point where he he was not losing
against stockfish